good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP we're going to be
looking at today is scp-1651
[Music]
Euclid special containment procedures
all instances of scp-1651 are to be kept
in frozen storage at site 23 testing of
these objects including the hatching of
scp-1651 a instances requires approval
from at least three level three
personnel all scp-1651 a instances are
to be kept in separate humanoid
containment chambers for the duration of
their lives a general feeding schedule
has been created for all scp-1651 a
however it appears that any given
instance requires a different diet or
schedule dr. Armstrong is to be
contacted and consulted
description scp-1651 refers to a
collection of seventy four eggs ranging
between 5 and 30 centimeters in length
they are normally white in coloration
though occasionally pink and red colored
eggs will also be found SCP 16:57 can be
indefinitely capped at temperatures
between 0 and 15 degrees Celsius if
these eggs are kept in conditions of a
certain temperature and humidity they
will hatch and yield specimens of
scp-1651 a c document 1657 alpha for
more specific details on the incubation
of these eggs scp-1651 a peer to be
closely related to humans Homo sapiens
sapiens except that they are not sapient
lack hair nails and teeth and are often
deformed sprouting extraneous appendages
or organs during regular growth
furthermore once hatched these entities
will grow to the size of an adult human
and reach maturity in approximately 13
days with the average total lifespan
being about 17 days SCP 1657 eight
instances are compliant and docile as
well as appearing to fear all living
organisms if the entity possesses
sensory organs it will use them in an
attempt to distance itself as far away
as possible from all other beings if
these aspects are not present the entity
will move away from something went
touched if left alone in a soothing
environment for a long period of time
SCP 1657 a may produce additional
instances of scp-1651
testing has shown that members of
scp-1651 a possess a collective memory
specifically this was discovered during
primary physical endurance testing when
scp-1651
a oh seven approached fire with
curiosity and subsequently died after
this point all individuals that hatched
showed great aversion and fear to fire
testing with alternative stimuli has
confirmed these results see test log
1657 kappa for the full log scp-1651 was
originally found in tennessee within the
house of a known high-ranking member of
GOI and subsequently contained six
packages holding 15 instances of
scp-1651
were found at this location and
subsequently contained each of these
packages are labeled in the same manner
with a flyer as transcribed in at end of
16:57 gamma
additionally blood that was later
identified as belonging to SCP 16:57
eight instances was found dried on to
several surfaces and appliances in sink
refrigerator and frying pans
addendum 1657 gamma to make this lecture
a little bit more entertaining I've
instructed acid to create a animated
version of the flyer hope you like it
restore eggs not working for you wish
you could have a goddamn masculine table
for once in your goddamn miserable life
by the man hey can it will make you man
never hear of you are what you eat have
we here if it's 100% goddamn that's why
we make our eggs out of real humans so
what are you waiting for go scramble and
eat off a man egg you muscular son of a
[ __ ] morning keep eggs refrigerated
whatever they are not being directly
used for cooking you not lay eggs
outside of a cold environment for more
than half an hour at a time if anything
emerges from your manic please call
actual human not using the videomatics
you have general even substitute Evo's
detailed nutrition facts can be found on
my website HTTP colon slash slash Dobie
Dobie hope you enjoyed that little
interlude I know I did
anyone for omelets just kidding I'm
never gonna eat an egg again this
concludes the lecture today so thank you
for listening if indeed you still are
and you are all dismissed goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to the reclusive extrovert GM's Sabah
Pablo ice 917 kareem l eschewing Traver
w peg white crew and jayvo jack
Bryce and Bailey my archive curator Nick
Tiber ball courts five six three and the
wanderer thank you all so much for your
support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos well on some other
cool stuff as well visit patreon.com
forward slash the volga thank you
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]